[Music]
we have fans of all ages got a lot of
young fans which is nice but we also
have older fans too you trouble notice
that now and then I'll bump into someone
who's older usually I'm used to seeing
kids young kids and they're like oh I
really like the show every now and then
I bump into someone who's older their
fans and so I thought if you happen to
be a fan of mine over the age of 50
maybe well this next piece is just for
you please welcome the bowel
owl hello everyone I'm the bow-wow
I fly all over the world teaching folks
about colon health by teaching them
about owls yeah okay
colon health and owls I don't really see
the connection
I'll show you fat owls have tiny comb
like Ridge feathers on their wings that
disrupt sound waves and allow them to
fly silently toward their prey you know
who else is a silent killer who call the
rectal disease if you're over 40 it's
time to give a hoot about your put -
okay well alright great a very important
message thanks for stopping by bowel owl
well there's more fact before Barnes
existed barn owls built their nests in
crevices caves and other dark places you
know who else also lives in dark
crevices who polyps
tiny clumps of cells that grow in your
colon most are benign but some become
malignant
who wants that yeah that's great it's
probably time to move the show along so
the colon it's Conan Oh Conan call it
either way that reminds me
fact owls have enormous eyes so more
light hits their optical receptors that
light bounces off the tavataan lucidum a
tissue that acts like a mirror to
enhance their night vision and that's
why Al's can see in the dark you know
who else can see in the dark a
[Music]
gastroenterologist by using a
colonoscope the good doctor would sit in
your colon
it's working its way through your meat
tunnel like El Chapo looking for free
night stop only stop it turn it off turn
it off we are done that was a disgusting
presentation well what you call
disgusting may have saved a life today
good day sir I'm starting to be honest
with you I've been doing this a long
time I think you're a horrible character
I said good day
[Applause]
you